all right so yellow jackets is all the
buzz as episode 3 delivers even more
questions very few answers and a human
hangover that'll take you back to your
college days but welcome back to heavy
spoilers you're home for uh what well
well heavy spoilers and in this video
we're going to be discussing everything
in this latest episode full on spoilers
callbacks and weird theories we have
give me a piece of that mint gum because
I'm seeing double baby anyway if you
enjoyed this video hitting that like
button is much appreciated and subscribe
to RSVP to Shauna's baby shower of
spoilers as we're covering this weekly
with that out of the way thank you so
much for clicking this I'm your host
Jared now let's get into Yellowjackets
episode three
so last week episode 2 ended with
everyone but coach Scott feasting on
Jackie's loins with us comparing it to
the Greek tragedy of the bakai and in
that with the main ads sobering up to
realize the horrible acts they partook
in the yellow jackets are very much
level-headed the next morning yeah
seeing uh the picked clean carcass of
Jackie they are responsible for it's
pretty [__] up and each girl has a
different reaction to it some ranging
from it is what it is and making jokes
guess
no one's breakfast
not the time Mari Jesus While others are
traumatized for life like Natalie here
but taisa's reaction is by far the
scariest with her not remembering any of
it supposedly being in her dream state
other persona while it went down last
week we guessed that there was more to
taisa than solely sleepwalking and we
get a bit more insight into this later
with a more aggressive side of taisa
lying underneath luckily Natalie steps
in suggesting they buried Jackie's bones
with the others at the crash site
allowing her a proper burial now coach
Scott did not partake in the Jackie
buffet and is both passive aggressive
towards the girls and a little freaked
out hallucinating they are going to eat
him which we all know is just a matter
of days away Coach Scott pretty much
dissociates from his current situation
to memories of him and his writer
boyfriend Paul before the crash
off in season one he mentions that Paul
wanted him to move in fully Embrace his
identity and relationship with Paul but
here we see how things truly play out
with him being scared of what will
happen after the move how will it affect
him his family career the two's
relationship the fear of the unknown or
rather the fear of letting his life be
known with Paul refuting in a far too
ironic way you always say those girls
are vicious little monsters he knew Paul
knew that crazy son of a [__] he knew
they are beyond happy together but this
is a huge Bugaboo for Paul and it's
implied they break up later though we
get to see the fork in the road an
entire what if scenario of Coach Scott
fully embracing Paul and the life that
could have been this really hit me in
the feels because he gets to be who he
truly wants to be and has his happy
ending but it's heartbreaking because
this isn't a reality he tried to play it
safe like most of us do to be honest and
it turned out to be a complete train
wreck or rather plane crash coach Scott
has pretty much lost hope he lost both
things he thought he cared about in life
Paul and his safe career and now where
is he stranded in the wilderness only
having one leg with a bunch of teenage
cannibals yeah no thank you and I have a
feeling this hopelessness spiral will
continue leading to him willingly ending
his life or surrendering to the greasy
mitts of the girls coach Scott isn't
gonna see those spring flowers The
Divide amongst Natalie and Lottie
continues as Natalie heads off to the
crash site but not before denying Lottie
of her Wicca [__] once again this
loner Persona she has later in present
day looks to be further developing here
even rejecting the help of Travis with
Jackie's remains Natalie says a bit of a
makeshift eulogy for Jackie's remains
showing a plethora of emotion Natalie
deeply regrets what happened to her
grateful because the others may now
survive from her sacrifice and expresses
how lucky Jackie was even in her death
she was able to make the others jealous
there's going to be a huge ramp up of
flesh eating in the coming months and it
is it it is not going to look good for
anyone now this feels very
lost-esque with the smoke monster in
that series but Natalie is greeted by a
majestic white moose obviously having
enough food to hold them over from
eating coach Scott prematurely Natalie
takes a shot misses far left as the
Moose charges her and runs off it's the
first game Natalie has seen in weeks but
why does this appear out of nowhere like
this well I think it's because Natalie
respectively returned Jackie's remains
therefore being a sign from the forest a
good omen in a sense because moose or
albino moose Miss mice mooses moose
moose carries several meanings ranging
from an animal of the spirit world
warding off evil spirits guidance
working with the opposition solidarity
and kindness I see this as a sign from
Jackie in the afterlife thanking Natalie
for being respectful of her even after
the horrifying night before this could
be a pure Spirit to otherwise ward off
the evil spirits that we've seen taking
play ever since season one also it's
said that killing a white moose will
bring bad luck so uh it's kind of good
that Natalie was a horrible shot present
day solidarity is something Natalie is
slowly learning from Lottie and her
followers a bit standoffish moseying
around the grounds which looks strangely
familiar to the Wilderness cabin with a
lake nearby when I go walking by Pope
Coke plays here in the music video for
this looks like a blind believer being
Guided by another which seems to be
Natalie and lottie's relationship at
this point though Natalie has a tough
exterior she is slowly being molded by
Lottie even wearing a dash of purple
later in the episode the big Scooby-Doo
Mystery of this right here is lottie's
secluded cabin of course we don't see
what's hidden inside like what is in
there man it does Sport a pair of
antlers on the outside though
symbolizing her time of the antler Queen
in the wilderness though it was never a
hundred percent revealed that it was her
this gives even more evidence that her
teachings may be based on things that
she learned back then in the wilderness
the bloodied Moss again has a close-up
of its own now back in episode 1 I
mentioned that the moss in the
wilderness on the weird Mossy tree and
around the cabin May symbolize some sort
of Supernatural darkness that is closing
in on the group and it is popped up in
every episode since then so uh drop your
Moss theories in the comments below
hashtag mosque now Lottie dropped some
of the most heavy-handed Illusions to
what the pair went through in the
wilderness in winter
and they vibrate to keep her warm when a
new Queen Hatches the first thing she
does is Sting all the other unborn
Queens to death I can see why you like
them it's simply what has to be done
otherwise they starve
we all do
[Music]
of course praising the antler Queen them
surviving the winter whoever stood up
against them was stung quote stung here
AKA made into their next meal to help
feed the others all of which sums up the
pit girl and the ceremony from season
one episode one again providing more
evidence to Lottie being the antler
Queen and done so for the survival of
the yellow jackets Hive I have a bit of
a theory about this that ties in with
Jackie's necklace You could argue Jackie
was the original Queen of the
Yellowjackets I mean she she was the
captain of the team after all however
she was quote stung therefore past this
designation on with the necklace being
the symbol of who the queen is akin to
that of the Conch Shell in The Lord of
the Flies novel which Yellow Jackets has
more than a few similarities to
currently Shauna wears the necklace so
she is the queen currently but maybe
down on the line Shauna loses this honor
if there are potentially complications
with her baby therefore again passing it
on because in the first episode pit girl
whoever she is is wearing the necklace
and my suspicion is that that is Mari so
how she receives it will be an
interesting Journey Natalie experiences
some more of lottie's unorthodox
teachings urging Lisa to reach in and
feel the anger and aggression she has
towards Natalie this flurry of emotions
puts Lisa in the position of Natalie and
understanding why she thrashed out at
her allowing for forgiveness to be the
overwhelming emotion in the end again I
think this is showing Natalie that she
can slowly trust and forgive Lottie for
the things that may have happened in the
wilderness 25 years ago and with what
happened with Travis that the pain of
carrying resentment should instead be
transformed into forgiveness Lottie
seems to have already gone through this
transformation so I'm curious if the
forgiveness was towards her veterans or
others back in the wilderness or
something else Jeff and Shauna's
marriage is very much on the Rocks as we
learned that one of the main reasons
Shauna went forward pursued the Adam
Martin Affair was because her life and
marriage is boring yes I mean we kind of
knew that but Jeff was the driving force
of that boredom again she grew into the
life of Jackie and what she wanted this
this isn't what Shawna wanted for her
life I mean this is a lot of people so
everything is mundane Shauna continues
by saying the idea of not knowing what
might happen was exciting to her the
idea of the unknown which is very
exciting to anyone this right here is
the concept Shauna has fully latched on
to and honestly is loving it while the
Adam Martin situation led to excitement
she hasn't experienced in let's say I
don't know 25 years since the Wilderness
and now with Kevin keeping an eye on her
this again is something that is exciting
the man that steals their van is another
exciting thing and her using the
tracking device from season 1 to track
the van back is maybe the most exciting
thing for Shauna there's an evil
Sinister side of Shauna that is
desperately trying to break free of the
Jackie mold and is loving this unclear
path she's slowly strolling down from
the conversation with a chop shop owner
it sounds like Shauna actually enjoys
killing Adam knocked something loose
that had been dormant for the last 25
years sure we know in the wilderness
things got hairy real quickly but Shauna
may be the one responsible for a lot of
the deaths back then essentially when
talking about the look in their eyes
there's a luck people get
when they realize they're going to die
[Music]
Shauna has a hunger punt pun intended
and no doubt Adam Martin is not going to
be the last one because with the
altercation between Kevin and Jeff at
the gym and Kevin knowing more than
anyone else about the Adam Martin case I
could see Shauna eliminated Kevin and
then pinning it on Jeff down the road
this gym incident shows potential motive
and Shauna would be free of the boring
prison she finds herself in taisa is
dealing with the ramifications of the
car accident from last week and yeah our
suspicions that there are two ties at
work is pretty much 100 confirmed with
her talking to a reflection in present
day and the other being in control of
the sleepwalking bouts back in the
wilderness now the interesting thing is
that this other tie seems to only have
control when taisa is sleeping dealing
with overwhelming amounts of stress
basically when she's not at a hundred
percent but also that this Persona knows
about the man with no eyes who I'm still
saying is some sort of harbinger of Doom
leading her straight to the symbol
carved into the tree now the weird thing
is that the sleep walking tie also seems
to know about the signs but the
conscience taisa doesn't this is shown
in the wilderness when she regains
Consciousness with van and seems to be
wary of when she finds the ritualistic
altar in her basement and the symbol
drawn on Simone's hand the symbol is a
warning sign maybe even a ritualistic
marking but nothing is a hundred percent
clear with that yet either way it's not
something taisa is thrilled about back
in season 1 when Lottie is possessed
something says You must spill blood or
else now Taissa was the one who wrote
spill in red paint on their front door
and having this symbol pop up after
sacrificing biscuit and purposely
spilling the blood of Simone I believe
that the other persona knows much more
than we're led to believe right now when
taisa confronts the other half in the
mirror one thing that she mouths is go
to her or at least this is what I think
moving her hands across her face like a
mask this is no doubt the other half
trying to tell taisa to go to van
because the hands on the face look like
that of Van's mask she wore after the
wolf attack in season one this also ties
in with taisa trying to call Jessica the
investigative reporter from season one
she's calling Jessica to help track down
and find van in present day so she can
ask her what the other half may want the
man with no eyes or even the symbol we
know from this new intro in season 2
that adult van is out there still alive
so I think we're gonna learn much more
about taisa from her the FBI informant
that Misty and Walter interrogate is of
course Randy I completely forgot he was
also staying at the motel so everyone
who commented it last week you've done
it you've solved the case but the funny
thing is Randy thinks that this is about
blackmailing and Adam Martin well Misty
thinks that this is something to do with
Natalie it's the worst case of uh who's
on first to be honest but luckily they
get a lead on lottie's purple goon squad
that they're hanging around drinking all
of the Fanta a couple weeks ago we
talked about Lottie wearing orange and
the purple followers being like
heliotrope flowers following the Sun so
it'll only makes sense that they would
drink all of the Fanta because orange is
the most popular flavor again they are
attracted to the Sun
[Music]
but the main thing to pull from this is
that Misty and Walter are one in the
same dressed in a similar clothing both
detective citizens eccentric possibly
borderline OCD and great at keeping
secrets or rather acting in Misty's case
because after the interrogation Walter
Reveals His Hand about wanting to
actually meet the infamous African gray
and coming clean about the woman not
being his mother however Misty sticks to
her guns and lies about Adam Martin
alright then keep your secrets
now one thing I do see happening between
the pair is a budding friendship or
potential relationship there are a few
reasons for this obviously that they are
very similar but Walter's boat is named
Great Expectations which may be
referring to the Charles Dickens novel
by the same name the novel follows an
orphan who seeks for a greater lot in
life until a twist of fate and the evil
machinations of the mysterious and
eccentric Ms havenchym shows him a dark
world of possibilities Walter may or may
not have a family revealing that again
the person he was Wheeling around was
just a friend and Misty has a dark
murderous side to her so she may
manipulate his otherwise innocent spirit
as things move on because they are
definitely a road trip and to find
lottie's gang next week but the way
Misty reacts to Walter and his text
later tells me that she's both ecstatic
and cautious of this new friendship now
my guess is that she's still broken from
whatever happened to Crystal in the the
Wilderness we see the two that they are
becoming great fast friends but there's
no trace of her in present day meaning
Misty either ate her killed her
manipulated or threw Crystal under the
bus to survive this is why this Walter
connection May mean a whole lot more to
Misty than we currently know another
reason we can assume Crystal's memory
still lives on with Misty is because of
her affinity for musicals back in season
one she mentions cats and listens to
Phantom of the Opera both of which tie
back to Crystal's love for the theater
musicals and acting Misty mentions the
ah of someone becoming someone else
while Crystal mentions were all made of
Lies Misty is the prime example of both
of these in present day again with
Crystal having made a big impression on
her another way to look at it could be
this wild out there Theory but one of
our editors suggested that Crystal is
actually Misty's imaginary friend what a
Twist I kind to believe it and there is
evidence with them sharing a love for
musicals and would make the Walter
friendship even more impactful we've
seen Crystal interact with the other
girls but it could all add to the
unreliable narrator point of views of
things the main thing happening back in
the wilderness is the makeshift baby
shower the girls throw for Shana and her
baby boy or at least that's what Lottie
says potentially seen a Future Vision
once again it's your everyday average
baby shower aside from a couple of
things first is Mari making a weird
potentially ritualistic dream catcher
mobile to hang above the baby crib but
also her randomly asking about a
dripping noise
okay there it is again
you guys really don't hear dripping now
I watched this a couple of times and I
couldn't hear anything so obviously it's
in mari's mind but as for what it could
be I'm seeing some sort of blood
dripping potentially tying in with the
dripping of Jackie's fingers and Bones
to open up this episode or alluding to
the blood that dripped on the blanket
later Lottie gives Shana with a blanket
that has the mysterious symbol sewn into
it this causes the two sides to once
again fracture but Shauna's bloodied
nose drips on the symbol resulting in a
flock of birds to randomly die falling
on the cab the reason for this is
unknown but back in season 1 during the
Seance night Lottie says You must spill
blood or else with the blood dripping on
the symbol it appears whatever
Supernatural forces are happy with this
and therefore they receive an offering
in exchange this could even be the
meaning of the bear heart Sacrifice by
Lottie which I have a feeling actually
hasn't happened yet it's something that
happens in the future maybe later in the
winter or even the second winter but we
even get a look at the smashed window
pane in the Attic of which we tied into
lottie's third eye being opened allowing
for the Visions Tori amos's bells for
her begins to play as the girl sort of
separate into their dueling factions
this song's meaning is talking about the
end of a friendship which I think is
alluding to van and taisa they have
already been on the rocks with Van
mentioning Lottie so much so I think
that this is the beginning of the end
for the two giving them even more reason
for present day taisa wanting to track
down van the episode closes with the
lottie's Visions intensifying showing
all of the bees dead and blood-soaked
honeycomb a terrible terrible metaphor
for Winnie the Pooh blood and honey but
rather this is a symbol for how the bees
mirror the yellow jackets in the
wilderness be tend to live on the bare
minimum so that they can all survive
much like the winter setting but when
the bare minimum isn't enough the queen
had to go in and kill the others for the
good of the entire Hive much like I
theorized about the necklace the queen
was in charge of picking who was the
next meal and with Lottie literally
having blood on her hands makes me
believe that she was also responsible
for a lot of the Bloodshed in the
wilderness Lottie hears more French
[Music]
be too
to follow you I think they say IL Voodoo
Sant which means good for you hinting at
what she did was good for her and the
others either way something is causing
lottie's Visions to intensify which
we're bound to find out soon before we
wrap up I have a crazy wild out there
Theory pulling from a lot of things but
I think the entire Wilderness
Supernatural elements can be explained
away because they are above a giant
underground mining operation
what yeah follow me here beneath them
are abandoned mines maybe even
containing hot springs and this is where
Javi has been hiding the heat also
explains why the weird Mossy tree seems
to be melted around the base and has
moss growing on it the symbols are
warning signs of hazardous chemicals
like mercury in the runoff maybe even
iron because of the red water from
season one The Iron also could explain
why the compass didn't work and why the
birds seemingly lost flight and fell to
the ground the hallucinations two come
from the runoff potentially everyone has
mercury poisoning and everything is a
warning I don't know let me know in the
comments obviously they are cooking a
lot so far so many questions but I'm
really digging this episode in this
season too and where they're trying to
take things really weaving it all
together with the underlying mystery
elements being the best part anyway that
is episode 3 of season 2 The showrunners
have a lot cooked talking right now the
cooking baby at this point but I'd love
to hear your theories and of course let
us know if we missed anything in the
comments below the necklace Theory maybe
it's out there crazy out there but there
might be something to it and I'll let
you know we're currently running a
competition giving away three copies of
the Superman collection on the 15th of
April and all you gotta do to get a
chance of winning this baby listen up is
like this video subscribe with
notifications on and drop a comment
below with your thoughts of
Yellowjackets episode 3. we picked the
comments at random at the end of every
single month and the winners of last
month are on screen right now so if
that's you message us on Twitter at
heavy spoilers if you want something
else to watch be sure to check out some
of our cool videos over there bunch of
old breakdowns Mario Super Mario Bros
tons of stuff but with all of that out
of the way seriously thank you thank you
so much for always watching support
everything I've been Jared I'll see in
the next one take care and peace